well we've been kind of waiting for this
escape off quite a while we've been
doing a lot to it we've raised a lot of
money stuff at that and we've done like
we've really put out like a fiddle to
get the skate park and we're just kind
of glad it's finally got there because
just rocked off fingers to the bone
doing some wing to do it she's taking a
while taking too long to be fair too
long fix am it's so good good enough
place to have it on seafront at least
would be sort of out of the public's way
we're a selfie out of our way as well so
hopefully you know if full things go
well it will look really really nice
would be nice to have something
something good skate that's close to
home and have to travel too far away and
there's about time really can you tell
us what you've done to get here what
sort of things have you been doing to
raise the money let the public know like
for a couple of grants and we yeah we've
done some grants for that and to loan
from the cancer sufferer that we've got
some money from one of their cancel it
counselors we and got got sum of money
put towards it we've done a lot of like
fundraising stuff at done a lot of
public consultations yeah suffer that
stuff from am also like carnival all the
events are happening our timber flighty
music events and all things that bring
to a local public into the one big area
you can kind of petition and you know
walk around questionnaires and if people
want this time on that and then they see
it's kind of like a number line okay so
possibility that a lot guys always well
in a lot of complaints but I think it
was this built I think it's going to
change my mind completely yeah
definitely can you tell us about this
design is it a great big huge half pipe
we're looking at well we kind of went
for more of a subtle way because we
forward we kind of at first dropped in
dependent for our way of everything big
everything that and then obviously like
no one obviously there's a lot of like
people that didn't want it so that so
then we kind of settled it down and we
made we made it like kind of a nice nice
shape ready like suited with the
seafront it goes would like to see so
far
be more beautiful yeah more yeah instead
of like a big blob blob of concrete it's
like actually it artist yeah like after
State Bar yeah yeah you can to operate
the facility there's there's going to be
the locals obviously we're going to have
a valid health and safety consultation
with the council and just underline all
the aspects that you you're going to
have to use to write use the facility as
well obviously safety comes first it's
probably gonna be like a helmet at all
times so feature that I think to be fair
people are going to become a bit so
fussy about wearing that helmet but the
end of the day so really its safety
safety first if I came down the crack my
head open now I'll be gutted and I think
that if that happens then someone's
going to come down pretty hard on you
and yeah anything you know you're not
being very responsible they've got to be
really responsible because we've like
petitioned and what we've worked oh yeah
we work for could just go straight down
the drain which is a very nice so it's
better to be safe than sorry isn't it
doing a group of us as well we're going
to be lucky as a team to keep
controllable with this as well so